[Orientalische Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es ein herzhaftes Rezept, nämlich einen Börek.
Ich habe schon verschiedene Versionen von Börek
auf meinem Kanal gemacht.
Da könnt ihr gern einmal auf meinem Blog
oder in meiner App vorbeischauen.
Börek gibt es wirklich in zahlreichen Variationen:
viele verschiedene Füllungen, Formen
es kommt aus der Türkei,
es gibt es jedoch auch in anderen Ländern dieser Welt.
Passend dazu möchte ich euch eine Aktion vorstellen,
nämlich von Kenwood.
Kenwood hat in der Aktion „1000 Flavors“ eine Studie beauftragt
und nachgeforscht, was denn so das Lieblingsessen der Deutschen ist.
Jetzt könnte man damit rechnen oder meinen,
dass z. B. Rinderrouladen, Sauerbraten oder Geschnetzeltes
unter den Top 10 oder Top 20 sind,
aber es ist gar nicht so.
Ich selbst muss auch sagen, dass die Deutschen,
also alle, die jetzt hier in Deutschland leben, sehr weltoffen sind
und die deutsche Küche an sich eigentlich auch nicht mehr existiert,
sondern es sind Einflüsse von der ganzen Welt.
Die Deutschen sind auch sehr offen, was Essen angeht.
Also wenn man einmal so fragt, wo geht ihr zum Essen gern hin,
ist es oft der Italiener, der Grieche, etwas Asiatisches
oder es gibt auch viele russische Spezialitäten,
türkische Spezialitäten.
Das finde ich echt schön,
weil man so mit einer Vielzahl an Essen aufwächst.
Gerade unter den Top 20, muss ich sagen, sind viele Gerichte dabei,
wie z. B. Sushi, Pizza, Burger –
„Knödel“ wollte ich sagen, ich meinte aber Kebap.
Ich glaube, zwei Gerichte waren dabei:
Das war einmal Sauerbraten und einmal Rouladen.
Aber alles andere ist schon sehr vielseitig.
Deswegen finde ich, dass Börek jetzt zur Aktion ganz gut dazu passt.
Ihr könnt auch gern auf dieser Webseite vorbeischauen.
Da gibt es nämlich ganz viele verschiedene Gerichte.
Vor allem könnt ihr dann auch sagen, was euer Lieblingsgericht ist.
Jedenfalls lege ich jetzt direkt einmal los.
Ich werde dazu einen Hefeteig zubereiten.
Das Ganze dauert eigentlich nicht allzu lange.
Ich zeige euch später auch ein paar Handgriffe,
wie es einfach funktioniert
und vor allem, wie es euch allen auch schmeckt.
Ich nehme dafür 1/2 Würfel Hefe, 1 TL Zucker,
jeweils 150 g Wasser und Milch, 1 Ei, 120 g Sonnenblumenöl,
1 EL Essig, 1 TL Salz und 600 g Mehl.
Jetzt könnt ihr zuerst einmal die Hefe in die Rührschüssel geben.
Dann Zucker und Wasser dazu.
Ich muss sagen, wenn ich jetzt hinter der Kamera koche und backe,
dann wiege ich die Zutaten vorher meist gar nicht so genau ab,
denn ich habe hier auch eine Waage.
Hier seht ihr das auch ganz gut.
Dann kann ich direkt die Zutaten auch hier hineinlegen.
Dann spart man sich natürlich auch viele Schüsseln und viel Geschirr.
Die Hefe kurz auflösen.
Man kann jetzt hier mit einem Vorteig arbeiten,
also hier noch ein bisschen Mehl darüber geben,
15 Minuten aufgehen lassen
oder ihr knetet einfach den Teig
und lasst ihn dann insgesamt aufgehen.
Der Vorteig hat immer den Vorteil,
dass dann das Gebäck insgesamt feiner wird
und der Teig schneller aufgeht.
Aber im Prinzip – ob man jetzt den Vorteig 15 Minuten
oder den Teig 15 Minuten länger aufgehen lässt –
eigentlich kommt es auf das Gleiche hinaus,
nur ist oft das Ergebnis ein bisschen feiner.
Aber ich finde, gerade bei so einem Börek fällt es gar nicht auf.
Dann gebt ihr jetzt einfach die restlichen Zutaten dazu.
Da achte ich nur darauf,
dass ich Salz und Fett immer am Ende dazu gebe,
damit es nicht direkt mit Hefe in Verbindung kommt,
damit sie gut aufgehen kann.
[Musik]
Ich gebe dann immer ein bisschen Hitze mit dazu,
damit der Teig schon schön warm wird und die Hefe arbeiten kann.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich den Teig 10 Minuten lang kneten lassen.
Ich habe auch die Zwischenzeit genutzt
und habe ich schon das Gemüse für die Füllung vorbereitet.
Deswegen ist es immer ganz gut, wenn man beide Hände frei hat.
Da ich hier direkt mit Hitze gearbeitet habe,
geht der Teig auch schneller auf.
Ich nehme den jetzt nur kurz heraus, forme ihn zu einer schönen Kugel.
[Musik]
Einfach hier kurz – der ist richtig schön geschmeidig.
Dann fette ich ihn ein bisschen auf der Oberfläche,
damit er nicht austrocknet und lege ihn in die Schüssel zurück.
Ich lasse ihn gleich in der Maschine weiter aufgehen,
aber ich brauche die Maschine zuerst,
um noch die Füllung herzustellen.
Dafür habe ich jetzt, wie gesagt, schon Gemüse vorbereitet.
Ich habe eine Zwiebel, eine große Knoblauchzehe,
Karotten und Kartoffeln – insgesamt sind es etwa 1 kg geschält,
das heißt, ich habe 600 g Kartoffel und 400 g Karotten –
etwas Petersilie, Salz, Pfeffer und Paprika edelsüß
und etwas Olivenöl – das war’s schon!
Das ist jetzt meine heutige Börekfüllung.
Murat hat sich nämlich gewünscht,
dass ich eine Börekfüllung mit Kartoffeln mache
– das mag er ganz gern.
Ich mag eher Börek mit Schafskäse.
Vielleicht mache ich später noch für mich
ein kleines Börek mit Schafskäse,
vor allem, weil auch die Kinder es auch gern essen.
Jetzt könnt ihr einfach die Zutaten entweder ganz fein hacken
oder fein raspeln.
Ich würde sie jetzt einfach alle raspeln.
Ich muss auch sagen,
wenn wir hier Salate, Saucen und anderes hier zubereiten,
ist bei mir der Multi Zerkleinerer immer im Einsatz.
Gerade bei Salaten – da mache ich es auch so, dass ich die
Salatblätter natürlich schnell wasche und schneide bzw. zupfe
und hier oben Karotten, Gurken und weiteres,
also was auch immer wir im Salat haben wollen,
schneide ich einfach darin
– Paprika, Frühlingszwiebeln, Gurken, Zucchini ab und zu.
Also alles kommt dort...
Rotkohl – ich habe wegen der Maske Gurke verstanden. [Lacht]
Du meinst Rotkohl.
Also da kommt wirklich alles durch.
Dann hat man innerhalb von 3-4 Minuten
einen richtig leckeren, bunten Salat.
Jetzt, wie gesagt, das ganze Gemüse oben hinein.
[Musik]
Dann ich die Füllung direkt anbraten.
Falls ihr keine Küchenmaschine mit Kochfunktion habt,
könnt ihr das natürlich auch in der Pfanne auf dem Herd zubereiten.
Ich gebe hier direkt das Olivenöl hinein, etwa 2 EL.
Dann kann ich es kurz erwärmen und sie erhitzt auch bis 180°C.
Also da kann man wirklich schön darin anbraten.
Da die Maschine mit Induktion arbeitet,
geht es auch wahnsinnig schnell.
Dann werde ich das Gemüse hier drin etwa 5 Minuten anbraten
oder, wie gesagt, 5 Minuten in der Pfanne,
kann nebenher noch die Petersilie feinhacken
und dann ist die Füllung auch schon bereit.
[Musik]
Die Füllung sieht jetzt schon einmal perfekt aus.
Jetzt kann ich direkt die Gewürze noch dazu geben.
Ich habe hier Paprika edelsüß.
Normalerweise mag ich es lieber scharf,
aber die Kinder essen nicht so scharf, Murat übrigens auch nicht.
Deswegen lieber edelsüß und ich kann bei mir noch nachschärfen.
Dann die Petersilie dazu.
Die Petersilienstile sind mir ein bisschen zu hart
und zu holzig darin,
aber die hebe ich gern auf und friere sie ein
- entweder für Suppen oder z. B. für Smoothies,
denn sie sind super gesund
und vor allem sehr lecker in einem grünen Smoothie.
Müsst ihr einmal ausprobieren!
[Musik]
Jetzt ist mein Hefeteig auch aufgegangen.
Seht ihr? Richtig schön!
Jetzt nehme ich ihn heraus.
Jetzt kommt es im Prinzip darauf an, wo ihr euer Börek genießen wollt.
Wenn ihr z. B. picknicken geht und das Ganze mitnehmen wollt
oder als Snack im Büro bei der Arbeit, in der Schule –
dann würde ich, glaube ich, die Börek länglich formen,
wie so kleine Zigarren und sie so backen.
Dann kann man sie gut aus der Hand essen.
Ihr könnt auch ein großes im Emaille-Blech backen,
z. B. in dem runden als große Schnecke.
Ihr könnt das Ganze aber auch eckig zubereiten
und kleine Schlangenlinien formen.
Ich finde es ganz schön
und mich erinnert es ein bisschen an meine Mama,
wenn ich Schneckennudeln mache, die so groß sind,
also kleine Hefeschnecken – so mache ich das jetzt.
Ich werde den Teig in 12 Portionen einteilen
[Musik]
und sie dann zu Kugeln formen.
Immer von außen nach innen praktisch,
dass der Teig rundherum glatt wird,
so nach innen ziehen.
Dann umdrehen, dann habt ihr schön die glatte Fläche.
Dann könnt ihr einfach mit der Hand hier einmal drumherum
und dadurch rollt ihr praktisch die Oberfläche nach unten
und alles bündelt sich da unten.
Dann habt ihr ein schönes glattes Brötchen.
Wenn ihr zwei auf einmal nicht könnt,
könnt ihr es auch in der Handfläche machen:
Nach innen zupfen, umdrehen und dann in der Hand.
[Musik]
Die Füllung habe ich jetzt hier auf einem Teller verteilt,
damit sie schnell abkühlt.
Sie ist bereit.
Jetzt nehme ich mir einen Teigballen.
Ich nehme immer den, den ich zuerst geformt habe,
weil er sich schon ein bisschen ausruhen konnte.
Jetzt könnt ihr den Ausrollstab oder ein Oklava nehmen.
Oklava nennt sich dieses Holzstäbchen.
Damit kann man den Teig nämlich extrem dünn ausrollen.
Mein Papa hat das Ganze immer aus einem Besenstil gemacht.
Auch ganz praktisch.
Sollte kein benutzter Besenstil sein.
Dann könnt ihr es hier immer dünner formen
und dann mit Hilfe von Mehl einmal drumherum wickeln.
Dann streicht ihr praktisch den Teig
mit den Händen am Stab nach außen.
Dann in die andere Richtung drehen.
So könnt ihr immer dünner formen.
[Musik]
Das sind jetzt 12 kleinere Röschen.
Ihr könnt auch einfach nur 6 Bällchen machen
und dafür umso größer ausrollen.
Je größer, umso größer werden natürlich auch die Schneckennudeln.
Ich halbiere jetzt hier den Teig.
Dann kommt die Füllung hinein.
[Musik]
Sie hat durch die Karotte eine echt schöne Farbe.
Murat wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen abgeschreckt sein
und fragen, ob es Kürbis ist.
Dann sage ich „Nein, das ist ‘ne Karotte!“
Dann aufrollen, ganz locker!
[Musik]
Hier zur Mitte hin zusammenrollen.
Das Ende verstecke ich immer darunter.
Dann könnt ihr es direkt auf ein Blech legen.
Falls ihr mit einem Oklava nicht auskommt,
könnt ihr den Teig auch einfach
mit einem Ausrollstab ganz dünn ausrollen.
Ihr könnt es aber mit der Pastawalze versuchen.
Vielleicht sogar hier mit dem Pastavorsatz von der Kenwood.
Da muss man nur darauf achten,
dass der Teig nicht zu weich, also nicht zu feucht ist,
damit es nicht klebt.
Aber wenn ihr es ansonsten nicht dünn hinbekommt,
dann ist es ein bisschen dicker.
Es ist ja ein Hefeteig; das ist auch okay!
So hat man einfach nur mehrere Schichten.
Was bei diesem Rezept ganz gut ist:
Ihr könnt es auch ganz einfach vegan zubereiten.
Die Füllung ist im Prinzip schon vegan.
Wenn ihr im Teig die Milch durch pflanzliche Milch austauscht
und das Ei weglasst
und stattdessen z. B. auch pflanzliche Milch dazugebt,
dann habt ihr schon einen veganen Teig.
[Musik]
Ich achte hier immer noch darauf, bevor die Füllung hineinkommt,
dass ich den Teig einfach ein bisschen vom Mehl befreie,
das heißt, einfach auf den Stab darauf nehmen, bisschen abklopfen!
Dann habt ihr die Mehlfüllung nämlich nicht in eurem Börek.
Das Mehl soll wirklich nur zum Ausrollen verwendet werden.
[Musik]
Das erste Blech ist jetzt fertig.
Das bestreiche ich direkt mit einer Mischung aus Ei und Milch.
Also einfach 1 Ei mit 1 EL Milch jetzt hier darauf.
Den Ofen habe ich jetzt nicht vorgeheizt.
Ich stelle nämlich das erste Blech
immer ganz gern in den kalten Ofen, schalte den Ofen dann an,
denn die Aufheizzeit nutze ich zur Aufgehzeit.
Das heißt, hier jetzt schön die Eimischung darauf,
dann mit Sesam bestreuen und backen.
In der Zeit mache ich das zweite Blech fertig
und dann kann das zweite Blech kurz warten.
Dann kann ich es anschließend in den Ofen stellen.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Mir ging jetzt gerade bei den letzten vier die Füllung aus.
Das heißt, falls ihr die Kartoffelfüllung für alle machen wollt,
solltet ihr darauf achten, dass ihr 1,5 kg Gemüse habt,
also 1,5 kg Kartoffeln + Karotte (geschältes Gewicht).
Dann müsst ihr mit der Füllung auch nicht zu sparsam sein.
Bei uns ist es jetzt ganz gut.
Ich schreibe es euch aber aktualisiert ins Rezept.
Bei uns ist es aber ganz gut,
denn die Kinder mögen sowieso lieber die Füllung mit Käse.
Dann nehme ich gern einfach einen Kuhmilchkäse.
Da kann ich den Käse nämlich einfach direkt hinein zerbröckeln,
mit Petersilie vermischen
und kann so noch kleine Börek für die Kinder formen.
Diese mache ich nicht schneckenförmig, sondern einfach länglich.
Die könnt ihr nämlich besser greifen und besser essen.
Dann sind die Kinder auch glücklich und nicht nur der Murat.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin auch lieber Fan von Käse.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr Börek-Sticks machen wollt, also lange Stäbchen,
dann einfach vierteln, die Seiten hier einklappen
und das Ganze dann schön aufrollen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich mein Börek fertig gebacken.
Murat darf gleich probieren.
Ich finde, Börek passt wirklich perfekt zur „1000 Flavors“,
zu der Kenwood-Aktion [Murat stimmt zu],
denn Börek gibt es auch in verschiedenen Variationen.
MURAT: Es gibt es in vielen Kulturen. Eigentlich kennt es fast jeder.
SALLY: Was ich eigentlich dein Lieblingsgericht?
MURAT: Mein Lieblingsgericht? Ich muss ehrlich sagen...
SALLY: Weil Kenwood hat eine Studie durchgeführt
und hat praktisch beauftragt zu forschen,
was das Lieblingsessen der Deutschen ist.
Da kam unter den Top 20 einfach nur zweimal ein deutsches Gericht
und der Rest waren Burger, Pizza, asiatisches Essen, Kebap.
Das zeigt einfach, wie offen die Deutschen für anderes Essen sind.
MURAT: Das hört sich jetzt voll blöd an, aber ich glaube,
nirgendwo auf der Welt gibt es so eine Esskultur wie in Deutschland.
SALLY: Ja!
MURAT: Weil es ist wirklich so, dass wir z. B.
wenn du in die Türkei zum Essen gehen würdest,
würdest du sehr, sehr lange suchen,
bis du mal einen Italiener findest. [Sally stimmt zu]
Du würdest extrem lange suchen,
bis du mal einen Chinesen findest. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Dann ist es eigentlich auch nicht italienisch oder chinesisch,
sondern das macht der Mahmut oder der Mehmet. [Murat stimmt zu]
Dann ist es so, ...
MURAT: In Deutschland ist es echt so:
In Deutschland findest du in der Stadt, sogar im Dorf einen Italiener.
Du findest einen Griechen, du findest einen Türken,
du findest einen Kroaten.
Das ist wirklich krass, was Deutschland hier isst [Sally stimmt zu]
und so offen,
weil die Deutschen sind für fremdes Essen extrem empfänglich,
wobei die deutschen Gerichte auch genial sind.
Ja, Wahnsinn! Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Also falls ihr da...
MURAT: Spätzle, Zwiebel und Spargel mit...
SALLY: Falls ihr da einmal nachschauen wollt,
dann könnt ihr bei „1000 Flavors“ nachschauen
und dort gibt es auch ganz viele weitere Rezepte.
Jedenfalls habe ich dir ein Kartoffel-Börek gemacht,
weil du dir ein Kartoffel-Börek gewünscht hast.
Meine Lieblingsfüllung ist eine Käsefüllung.
Du hast gesagt „Kartoffel“ und ich war ganz stolz darauf,
dass du nicht gesagt hast „Hackfleisch“.
MURAT: Das schmeckt auch toll, aber...
SALLY: Das schmeckt auch gut, aber...
MURAT: Ein bisschen weniger Fleisch; mit Kartoffeln ist richtig cool!
Ich liebe es, von meiner Mutter... Meine Mutter hat das immer gemacht.
SALLY: Okay, ich geh dann mal. Da komm ich eh nicht dagegen an.
MURAT: Du kannst es essen.
Schatz, du kannst es nicht besser als meine Mutter machen.
Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Es ist unmöglich.
SALLY: Mamas kochen anders!
MURAT: Mamas kochen immer am besten.
SALLY: Nimm die, dann verbrennst du dich nicht.
Diese sind noch zu heiß.
Guck mal, wie ich dich davor beschütze, dass du dich verbrennst.
MURAT: Mmh! Mmh! Voll lecker! Ehrlich!
SALLY: Echt jetzt? [Murat stimmt zu]
Habe ich das Mama-Siegel?
Ich will kein Mama-Siegel. [Lacht]
MURAT: Gut. Kommt an meine Mutter fast ran.
SALLY: Ja?
MURAT: Ja, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Du, ich muss gar nicht so gut kochen können wie deine Mama.
MURAT: Aber ich würde gern noch einen Freund probieren lassen.
SALLY: Ja?
MURAT: Ich liebe es immer,
Menschen in eine peinliche Situation zu bringen.
SALLY: Ich weiß.
[Murat lacht]
MURAT: Ich liebe das.
Und das sind Menschen, die haben jetzt gar nicht damit gerechnet.
Die haben mich einfach besucht.
So habe ich einen Freund hier, den Hakan.
So, Hakan kommst du kurz bitte?
SALLY: Hakan, gel! (Hakan, komm!)
MURAT: Er ist sichtlich peinlich gerührt,
weil damit hat er jetzt nicht gerechnet. Genau.
Hakan, du brauchst keine Angst zu haben.
Du hast deine 7 Jahre im Zuchthaus schon abgebüßt.
Deswegen ist es völlig in Ordnung.
SALLY: Hör nicht auf ihn! Hör nicht auf ihn!
MURAT: Der Hakan...
SALLY: Komm zwischen uns. Dann hört man dich besser.
MURAT: Hakan hat ziemlich abgenommen.
Er hat eine Sauerstoffdiät gemacht. Richtig?
[Sally lacht]
Eh, eine Stoffwechseldiät, Entschuldigung! [Hakan stimmt zu]
Wie viel Kilo hast du abgenommen? Sei mal ehrlich!
HAKAN: 30 Kilo!
MURAT: 30 Kilo hat er abgenommen.
SALLY: Die hast du jetzt zugelegt.
MURAT: Ich habe... Bei ihm war es Stoffwechseldiät,
bei mir war „Stoff“-wechsel einfach sich umzuziehen
und schwarz anzuziehen.
So Hakan, probiere mal, ob...
HAKAN: Ich will aber mit Käsefüllung.
SALLY: Da ist es mit Käse. Ich bin auch Team Käse,
aber nur mit Gazi Peynir (Gazi Käse).
MURAT: Du kannst ruhig ehrlich sein, weil...
HAKAN: Top lecker!
MURAT: Ehrlich?
Mmh! Ja!
HAKAN: Oh, ich liebe Käse. [Murat und Sally stimmen zu]
SALLY: Ich habe Kartoffel Karotte gemischt,
aber ich bin auch mehr bei Käse.
Das ist auch lecker, mit Gemüse, muss ich sagen.
MURAT: Boah, ich habe gerade aus Versehen...
SALLY: Murat isst gleich beide zusammen.
MURAT: Ich habe aus Versehen ein großes Stück runtergeschluckt,
ohne zu kauen – das hat gerade voll wehgetan.
HAKAN: Es ist heiß, aber es schmeckt sehr, sehr lecker!
SALLY: Ja! Was ich sagen wollte: Man kann es warm oder kalt essen.
Wenn ihr eine große Menge zubereitet,
ich meine, es ist schon ein bisschen aufwendig
das Ganze mit Oklava auszurollen,
dann könnt ihr es auch abkühlen lassen, einpacken und einfrieren.
Dann habt ihr immer etwas auf Vorrat.
MURAT: Hakan, möchtest du noch Leute in Duisburg grüßen,
wenn du schon hier im Fernsehen bist?
HAKAN: Nein.
SALLY: Im Fernsehen!
MURAT: Also wenn ihr in Duisburg irgendwo Hakan an der Straße seht,
macht bitte die Tür zu! [Lacht]
Schließt sie ab!
SALLY: Macht das lieber, wenn der Murat in der Nähe ist.
Also viel Spaß beim Backen, beim Zubereiten.
Teilt gern eure Rezepte mit mir
und schreibt mir einmal, was euer Lieblingsgericht ist,
gern in die Kommentare!
MURAT: Da gab’s mal eine Serie mit zwei Autoverkäufern, oder?
Kennst du es noch?
SALLY: Murat und Hakan, oder wie?
MURAT: Ja, Murat und Hakan. Hier!
Murat und Hakan.
SALLY: Oh, ihr zwei als Autohändler!
MURAT: Wir werden Autohändler: Die zwei Autohändler!
Wie Schrott und Trödel. Hakan und Murat.
SALLY: Ja komm, lass doch uns einmal analysieren, die Sally Community.
Was das Lieblingsessen der Sally Community ist.
Schreibt einfach gern alle euer Lieblingsessen in die Kommentare.
Gucken wir einmal, wie bei uns der Durchschnitt schmeckt.
MURAT: Ich bin mal gespannt, wie oft Döner kommt.
Früher war es wirklich so, man hat immer gedacht,
die Currywurst ist das Lieblingsessen der Deutschen.
SALLY: Ich gehe schon mal. Tschüss!
MURAT: Und dann war es nachher der Döner.
HAKAN: Ich gehe auch mal.
SALLY: Gel Hakan, gel! (Komm Hakan, komm!)
HAKAN: Ich esse eine Kartoffelvariante.
MURAT: Ja, okay.
Und ich erzähle euch noch ein bisschen was über Esskultur.
Also wirklich:
Deutschland - sagt, was ihr wollt – die geilste Esskultur der Welt!
Wobei die Amerikaner auch nicht schlecht sind.
Nur das Problem ist, dass die Amerikaner immer alles einverleiben
und dann mixen.
Dann gibt es z. B. ein Croissant und ein Donut.
Dann machen die ein Cronut daraus.
Ist wirklich so!
Und das machen die Amerikaner: Die mixen immer Sachen.
Das ist fürchterlich manchmal.
Ganz fürchterliche Kombinationen.
Die Deutschen lassen es einfach, wie es ist
und machen tolle Sachen. Ja.
SARAH: Darf ich das Blech nehmen?
MURAT: Ja, natürlich! So.
SALLY: Aber rede noch ein bisschen weiter.
Dann können wir so ein Fast-Ding daraus machen, weiß du?
So ein Zeitraffer.
Sarah holt schon die Börek.
Genau, du redest weiter.
MURAT: Okay.
Es ist der Unterschied zwischen Esskultur...
Tschuldigung, ich drehe gerade ein Video!
Ich erzähle gerade etwas!
SARAH: [Lacht] Ich muss fotografieren.
MURAT: Ja. Es gibt auch unterschiedliche Esskulturen.
Also die Esskultur in Deutschland ist genial.
Über das Essen können wir immer reden.
Vom Essen her finde ich die Österreicher fast noch cooler.
Ich finde, die Österreicher geben...
Zwischen Österreicher und Deutschen ist der Unterschied ganz einfach:
Der Österreicher gibt 30 % mehr aus für Lebensmittel
und der Deutsche 30 % mehr für das Auto.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Deutschen und Österreichern.
Ich muss sagen, die Österreicher haben eine geile Küche!
Wiener Schnitzel liebe ich.
Plachutta in Wien – ganz toll!
SALLY: Aber woher kommt das Wiener Schnitzel ursprünglich?
MURAT: Das Wiener Schnitzel kommt eigentlich...
Übrigens, das habe ich gestern gesehen.
Ihr werdet es mir nicht glauben.
Ihr werdet jetzt denken „Der Typ hat einen Dachschaden!“
Aber es ist wirklich bewiesen.
Gebt mal ein: Galileo Wiener Schnitzel.
Nein, Schnitzel, nur Schnitzel.
SARAH: Darf ich raten?
MURAT: Woher kommt’s?
SARAH: Istanbul.
MURAT: Ja, woher weißt du das? Hast du gesehen, gell?
SARAH: Nein, Sally hat’s mir erzählt!
MURAT: Wusste ich auch nicht.
Aber ich finde es immer krass, wenn sie immer sagen:
„Das ist von uns, von uns!“
Das ist ein dummes Geschwätz.
Du weißt es nicht.
Aber es ist wirklich so, dass das Schnitzel aus der Türkei kommt.
SALLY: Und in wie viel Fußballfeldern wird es gerechnet bei Galileo?
MURAT: Das wird... Keine Ahnung! Hör auf, mich zu verar***en.
[Sally lacht]
So. Was ich auch nicht wusste:
Z. B. Nudeln – Nudeln, denken ja viele, kommen aus Italien.
Falsch! Nudeln kommen aus China. Ja.
Wusstet ihr das? Wusstet ihr nicht!
Jetzt seid ihr alle schlauer.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt noch unter der Rubrik...
SALLY: Warum machen die Deutschen viele Schmorgerichte
und die Asiaten nicht?
MURAT: Und zwar, pass auf! Genau. Das ist auch eine coole Geschichte.
Die Asiaten z. B. machen keine Schmorgerichte,
weil Schmorgerichte brauchen ja viel Holz,
aber die Asiaten hatten kein Holz.
Also haben sie alles schnell machen müssen. Schnell halt!
Chinesen – ganz schnell!
Deswegen gab’s da keine Schmorgerichte.
Deswegen machen die immer kurz Gebratenes und Gegartes.
Stimmt auch wieder, gell?
Das ist wieder aus der Rubrik
„Hätte es Murat nicht gesagt, dann wäre ich dumm gestorben!“
Ja. Okay?
Also es hat mich wirklich gefreut, mit euch zu reden.
Mein Name ist Murat.
Bis zur nächsten Geschichtsstunde von mir.
Macht’s gut! Tschüss!
Genug geredet. Weiter essen!
„1000 Flavors“ nicht vergessen!
[Musik]